foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my movie review series now this
movie here Starry Eyes
um I might have mentioned it on some
other reviews or like some other live
streams that I've done stuff uh before
because I've actually seen this movie
several times probably like two three
four times at this point and I
absolutely adore this movie and for some
reason I thought that I had already
reviewed it for this series but then
when I looked through all my bat catalog
I was like how could I not have talked
about this movie I mean I guess the
thing is I saw it like a few times like
before I started doing these like solar
reviews and stuff like that so maybe
that was when maybe it just kind of like
fell through the cracks because I
thought I'd already done it but when I
looked through there and I was like holy
I can't believe I haven't talked
about this movie so I really need to do
something about that like as soon as
possible because I really really do like
this movie a lot and I think that more
people should see it so this movie is
actually uh getting on a bit now it's
which is crazy it's almost 10 years old
at this point it came out in 2014
actually premiered at the South by
Southwest film festival in that year now
this was actually written and directed
by Kevin kolsh or kelsh or something
like it's you know it's got an um loud
so I'm trying to like I didn't take
German so I don't know how to pronounce
it and uh Dennis Whitmire who you know
pretty well known in the horror
Community they also directed The 2019
pet cemetery remake which me it wasn't
all that good but it wasn't that bad you
know what I mean but yeah so they did
that I'm not gonna hold that against
them though because this movie was like
pretty Dynamite
um and this movie was actually this
might have been their first movie they
directed I'm not entirely sure the first
full-length movie and it was actually um
partially funded through a Kickstarter
campaign and when it came out back in
2014 it got a ton of really really
positive press and a lot of Buzz and
honestly like seeing it when I finally
got around to seeing it it was pretty
easy to see why it what it is it's
essentially an homage to kind of like
the Classic 60s and 70s era satanic cult
kind of movies I got shades of like
Rosemary's Baby or to the devil a
daughter or something like that but then
there's also an aspect of like a David
Lynch Dark Side of Hollywood type of
thing like in Mulholland Drive or Inland
Empire or something like that so it's
almost kind of like those two things put
together and then there's also an aspect
of like cronenbergian body Horror in it
too so it's kind of got something for
everybody so this movie I found this
movie the first time I saw it like I
said I loved it so much that I've seen
it a couple times since then and I mean
it's just really it's kind of disturbing
it's like really gross really violent
um also has like a black comedy kind of
tinge to it but not overtly it's like
kind of subtle and I just really really
got into it um it's a pretty it's fun
but it's also like kind of like I said
like dark and disturbing and sort of
grim and also kind of a really cynical
meditation on sort of like the lengths
that people will go to for fame
um you know just the whole soul sucking
nature of the Hollywood System in
general and how um having like
unfettered ambition can kind of like
corrode your soul essentially now I'm
gonna say that easily my favorite thing
about this movie is the lead performance
of Alex Esso and I this was kind of like
her breakout role
she just goes for it in this movie um
and I love actresses that do that
particularly in horror because she makes
her protagonist who is you know a
up person I mean she really has some
problems but she's real grounded and
believable still but at the same time
like she manages to come off as like
sort of sympathetic but also monstrous
and I think that's like a really good uh
thing to pull off like she does a really
good uh balance with that and you know
anybody that's real into horror you know
that she's actually since gone on since
this movie came out um she's gone on to
like a lot more high profile kind of
roles
um and she's pretty much killed it and
every single thing that I've seen her in
um she's done some work with Mike
Flanagan she actually had a small role
in uh you know the Netflix series
Haunting of blind Manor and she also
played Wendy in Dr sleep you know the um
The Shining sequel from 2019 and she was
actually like really great in that I
really liked her in that so in Starry
Eyes um Alex Esso plays a girl named
Sarah Walker
and she is just one of millions of other
young women in La trying to make it like
as a movie star now to pay the bills uh
she actually works at this very dreary
like Hooters type restaurant uh which is
called Big taters but you know obviously
she feels like this is just a stop Gap
and she's destined for much bigger and
better things so she's been kind of
going out for a bunch of auditions but
she always gets rejected and like I said
she has real
um real bad like insecurity issues and a
lot of like deep-seated self-hatred so a
lot of times like should go out to an
audition and she doesn't get it and then
she kind of goes into these things where
she's like pulling out her own hair and
like going into these like just
psychotic rages and stuff but nobody
sees them but her like she does it in
secret because she feels like she's
failing and she has to like constantly
like punish herself and denigrate
herself and like that so she's like
self-harming essentially and another
thing that's really not helping her
mental state I guess is uh all of these
quote unquote friends that she has now
she does have a couple friends she has
like a roommate named Tracy and this
other guy who's like an indie film
director who's like a friend of hers who
are actually like pretty supportive of
her but then she has like these other
kind of friends Hangers On like in her
group like you know what I mean that are
just kind of like you just kind of enjoy
like cutting her down or something like
that and there's this one quote unquote
friend of me that she has in particular
who's this real passive aggressive
like his name is Aaron and she is just
continually chipping away at Sarah's
self-esteem with just these backhanded
like compliments and just like like I
said just constantly denigrating her
with these little offhand comments that
she makes she's like super super
now even though Sarah has all of these
problems and insecurities and stuff like
that she does actually manage to pull
off kind of a decent audition for a
horror movie which is casting called the
silver scream and this movie is
supposedly produced by this kind of
long-running well-known production
company which is called Estrellas films
only problem is when she goes into the
casting thing like she does a good job
but her performance really isn't
anything special it's just kind of like
it's good but it's just like all the
others you know I mean she doesn't super
stand out so she actually just kind of
gets dismissed by the super creepy like
casting agents it's like a man and a
woman and they're like really really
creepy they're just like um thank you
next you know what I mean so it's that
kind of so after this audition she
kind of knows that she whiffed it so she
goes into the bathroom like in this
building or whatever and just
loses it so like I said she's just in
the thing and she's just Primal
screaming and just yanking her hair out
and all this other kind of
and wouldn't she know it but the woman
the female casting agent comes in the
bathroom and sort of witnesses this
freak out that she's having and so the
woman is now she's like super interested
because she's like oh maybe this girl
does have like something to offer you
know what I mean she's like why don't
you come back to the casting office and
reenact this tantrum that you had for us
um because we want to see the real you
so as the movie goes on Sarah gets
callbacks uh just for more auditions and
everyone just gets kind of weirder and
sketchier until she eventually gets
called to meet the producer of this
movie The Silent Scream who is just this
overly tanned you know leering old creep
who very predictably wants to make a
essentially like a Faustian bargain with
Sarah basically asking her to give
herself up both body and soul for fame
is is essentially what the deal is so it
really shouldn't come as a surprise to
anybody that Sarah is not really being
recruited for a horror movie per se but
she's kind of being initiated into like
a satanic cult of Hollywood Elites
um and of course this cult is going to
require sacrifice
in order to achieve the final
transformation uh which will be from
kind of like a struggling nobody actress
and also breast waitress to kind of a
very glamorous like Tinseltown screen
Idol so like I said it's kind of like a
Faust story so as I said because it's
like a foul story
um you know and the plot is like that
it's so it's not like um you know it's
kind of like familiar territory it's a
story that's been done a lot of times
but that is absolutely not a ding
against it um honestly the whole fun of
this movie is kind of watching Sarah
just horribly spiral downward as she
pretty much just like siphons off little
bits of her soul to kind of like achieve
her Ultimate Dream of Fame she wants to
be a movie star you know what I mean so
she actually does accept the cult
invitation and after that she this is
where the body horror comes in
because at this point she starts to
physically deteriorate I mean into just
an appalling degree I mean so much so
that you're watching it and you're kind
of like revolted but you're also kind of
intrigued you're just kind of like you
don't really want to see like whatever
disgusting indignity is gonna happen to
her body next but you're also it's also
like a train wreck like you can't really
like look away from it like it's pretty
gross and I gotta say too again like
Alex Esso is like outstanding in
this she just like she just goes
for it man it's just like there is
really something about an actress that
is willing to lay themselves bare like
this um I mean she puts like real
maggots in her mouth it's just I mean
she goes the distance and it's
like I I totally respect that
and I think like her performance too
it's so like as I watched her in it I
kind of found myself you kind of hate
her because she's weak uh she's naive
um she's willing to give up everything
just for this what seems like a shallow
goal but at the same time you also
empathize with her because she's kind of
like an outsider she's very insecure
she's got a lot of problems and you can
kind of sympathize with the way that she
feels about herself and like kind of you
know you kind of want to take care of
her because she's kind of like hates
herself so much and you know and the
fact that she's willing to do all this
stuff to like achieve her dream and
you're almost kind of like you hate her
but you're also kind of like rooting for
her at the same time and like you're
kind of like hoping that she gets what
she wants even though she has to do all
this up to get it and I mean
the fact that I could feel all of these
emotions about her at once I mean that's
kind of like really a testament to Alex
esso's acting performance in this which
is just amazing it's just really really
good and I mean not to on the other
actors too because pretty much all the
other actors in This are also great and
I thought one of my favorite things
about it was that I thought it was great
how even characters like Aaron who was
the like the friend and the big
taters manager whose name was Carl he
was actually played by Pat Healy who's
in like tons and tons of movies that
were kind of supposedly villains or
antagonists at least from Sarah's point
of view because they were like in the
way of her goals but even they were
given like a lot of humanity and a lot
of Dimension like even though they did
and said like some shitty things and
like I said we're kind of standing in
her way they did still genuinely care
about her well-being
which made you know the act of her kind
of like viciously turning on them near
the end like all the more devastating
because everyone was very
three-dimensional like very fleshed out
you know gotta say to you the special
effects in this are really really good
um Sarah's bodily disintegration like I
said very grotesque uh very nauseating
like I said it's just teeth it was just
it's super gross it's super gross also
this it had like some pretty really
nasty like brutal violence in it and the
way it's portrayed is just very
unsettling because it's very like matter
of fact there was one kill in particular
like toward the end where I mean the
camera just like doesn't even Flinch as
someone's head just gets pounded into
pulp uh which
I had a hard time watching it to be
honest it was like it was pretty
it was pretty rough but yeah so
so that's all great
um the film actually has like a great
score and really really good sound
design which you know are things that I
really appreciate when they stand out to
me so I feel like just putting all those
things together and this was just like a
great this was a blast of a movie I you
know and I know that everybody has
different opinions and I've know some
people had seen it and they didn't
really care for it and stuff like that
but this is actually probably
one of my favorite
um horror films like from the last
decade or something like that there's
something about it that like really
resonated with me and like I said I
thought it was really it kind of had
it had like something for everybody like
I said it kind of had like a throwback
vibe to it like a Rosemary's Baby or
satanic cult kind of thing but then it
was also kind of modern had kind of like
a little bit of a you know dark
Hollywood kind of thing to it like I
said had a little bit of subtle black
humor which I was kind of into so and it
had all that Gore the body horror and
like that that was really good so
it really just kind of had it was just
like a good balanced mix of everything
and I really really dug it so I mean if
you're into that kind of thing if
anything I said about that like sounds
super intriguing or anything you should
definitely check it out don't watch it
if you're squeamish I'm gonna say
probably don't watch it while you're
eating you know what I mean I'm just
because I I've seen it like three or
four times and it's it's not the
grossest thing I've ever seen but it is
kind of like you know what I mean there
is some kind of like revolting in
it so it's like you know like I said if
you're squeamish you might not dig it
but other than that I try to like
recommend it to most people that ask me
for recommendations if they haven't seen
it especially if they like 70s satanic
cult kind of stuff because that's kind
of where it's coming from but yeah I
really dug this a lot I'm not actually
sure where it's streaming right now it
might be on 2B if I'm not mistaken I
think the first time I saw it I might
have seen it on shutter but I don't know
if it's on there anymore but usually the
movies from this era like they come and
go on 2B so you should probably check
and see if it's on there but I really
like this a lot um like I said it came
out in 2014 and it's called starry eyes
and please let me know what you thought
about in the comments if you've seen it
if you liked it didn't like it or
whatever and that will do it for this
flickers of fear and I will see you guys
again on the next one bye